so now we're going to do uh yakam
manucci and um the hand shapes again so
uh
Dy so they come Yaman you can either
come in here bring the hand down but
look what's happened
now
naturally you got that thumb where it
needs to be and that one comes
over but sometimes
techniques rather than in if I was to go
now
round sometimes this one gets in the way
and this one goes on top and if you
always remember the one closest to
him is at the bottom the one closest to
him is at the
bottom so we're going to do not the one
that's natural and works
out easy for
you we're going to do the one that
you've got to think about and put the
thumb in the right place so you've got
to place that thumb okay so it's here
here
here here
okay it's up to you whether you take
your cam or not